The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This
morning's SIAM News.
Well, it's an
article on something
that's not totally up to date
because it's a method that
was developed 50 years ago
called alternating direction
and it was exactly
developed-- first
you did an iteration
in the x direction.
Of course, we're
tridiagonal along every row,
we're one-dimensional.
And then the second
half-step is an iteration
in the y direction.
Again, tridiagonal, so
the iteration's very fast.
You flip-- alternating direction
describes it perfectly.
And that method is still used.
It got developed in the oil
reservoir simulation world.
That is, Houston.
And the article
says the evolution
of techniques for oil reservoir
simulation has continued.
And then mentions 3-- so it went
from this alternating direction
to line overrelaxation,
LSOR, overrelaxation,
and I only spoke
briefly about that.
What's that word line mean?
That means that we're
taking whole rows at once,
working with blocks.
And I'll add some
notes about that today.
So that was the
next step, line SOR.
Then to the Newton-Krylov
schemes, that's what's coming,
Krylov, Conjugate gradients,
with ILU type preconditioners.
So again, we're talking
about preconditioners
and one important choice
is this incomplete LU.
So notes on Gauss-Seidel and I
should maybe add incomplete LU.
By the way, experiments
badly needed here too.
Because incomplete LU has
this tolerance and as you
move the tolerance you
get closer or far away
to the exact L and U, but
you get faster or slower.
So what's the balance?
What's the right tolerance?
How do these methods
compare-- and overall,
how do these iterative methods
that we're speaking about
compare with these
direct methods?
So we really are in this new
chapter, solving large systems,
facing a whole lot of
possible new experiments.
So just to continue the history
or the future as described
in SIAM News, so there was
alternating direction, line
SOR.
Then to Krylov schemes with ILU
preconditioners in use today.
So this is a big use area.
And the multiscale, multigrid
solvers that are quote,
now starting to come of age.
So that's a third topic for
today's lecture, multigrid.
That-- of course, it's
been around for some time,
but it involved,
especially at the start,
more effort in programming.
So it didn't quickly-- I
mean, it gave great results
on model problems.
On other problems,
too, but still
it kind of hasn't yet,
but is penetrating
into production code,
where the oil reservoir
industry or other big
industries would use it.
So here you see, really, a
pretty fair picture of where we
are today with large solvers.
These are very important.
Minimum degree-- if the
size is not overwhelming,
direct methods are going
to be right up there.
And these are the
pure iterations,
stationary iterations that, with
this idea, this incomplete LU
idea, get pretty good.
But the formula's
always simple there.
The new x comes from the old
x by the same iterations.
Whereas, if we use
the ideas there as
preconditioners and look
to see-- so the point was,
and I'll repeat it again,
that Gauss-Seidel and Jacobi,
the standard iterations,
were quite satisfactory
on high frequencies.
They damped those out
quite well in the error,
but they don't tackle the low
frequency, the smooth part
of the error, very efficiently.
And that's what multigrid
does incredibly well, so it's
a nice mixture of the two.
These are the smoothers,
this is the change
of scale, change of grid that's
coming now and will come.
So all this will be my subject
for this week and next,
prior to spring break.
And I think you will have enough
to go on to do experiments.
It could be highly interesting.
OK, so that's the
SIAM News report.
OK, what do I want to
say about minimum degree?
And more will go on the web.
Just a few more notes about what
we did on Monday after class.
If you take a matrix like
that, you take a matrix
and-- how is it described
in sparse format?
Sparse format you can
see-- normally you
don't have to see
it, it's usually
inside the sparse
MATLAB, but if you
want to see what's happening,
you could ask for i, j, and s.
Now what are those?
What will that
produce? i will be
the list of nonzeros,
the list of the row
numbers of the nonzeros.
So i will be-- maybe I'll write
it as a row so I'm transposing,
So the row numbers would
be row 1, row 2, not row 3.
Row 1, 2, 3, row 2, 3.
The column numbers
would be-- these
are going to be
the pairs (i, j).
So that's column 1 twice,
column 2 three times.
Column 3 twice.
And what's s? s is the actual
numbers in position (i, j),
is the number 2.
In position (2, 1) is
the number minus 1.
So those numbers, minus 1,
2, minus 1 is that column.
And then minus 1,
2 is that column.
So of course, we've got all
the information in the matrix.
We know every nonzero position
and we know what that entry is.
And of course, our matrices
are much bigger than this one,
but already we can see
one useful point-- point
being that key word-- that the
column numbers, this-- I mean,
imagine we have a large
matrix, so this j is not
very efficiently recorded
here because what's j?
We're looking at nonzeros
a column at a time,
so of course, we'll have a few
ones for the nonzeros in column
1 and then some twos and then
some threes and some fours,
but all this row is-- the
real information in that row
is a pointer to--
in other words,
I don't have to
repeat 2 three times.
So really, if I put inside
here a compressed version
of j, a pointer, would be a
short factor that just has a 1.
It says look in position 1
for the start of column 1.
Then a 3-- see, I didn't
need that because that just
continued column 1.
That just repeated
the j I already had.
But this tells me that
in the third position
I start down column 2.
And this would tell me that
in position number 4, 5, 6,
I guess, I start down column 3.
You see the point of that 6.
That 6 picks out--
yes-- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
the sixth row number
is the beginning
of information on column 3.
And then it's
conventional to have
a pointer, 8, to say finish.
So that's pointing
to empty space.
So in other words, j got
compressed to 1, 3, 6, 8
and in a large problem it
would get seriously compressed.
OK, so that's the form in
which the code keeps the matrix
and does the reorderings.
Let me just mention that
the opposite of this
would create the matrix
out of these i, j, s.
What command would that be?
You could create the matrix
A out of-- the command sparse
would be good.
Sparse of the inputs,
now, would be i, j, s.
If I input i, j, and s then
that lab creates a matrix.
And sometimes I
may want to include
the m and n, the shape of the
matrix, as further parameters,
but actually here
I wouldn't have to.
So this is the opposite
command from this one
that we're interested in.
You can imagine.
Suppose by using minimum
degree or some other decision,
I've eliminated up
to a certain point
and I want to put the remaining
columns in a different order.
I can do that just by
playing with the pointers.
So it's a very efficient
structure for sparse matrices.
And then comes the question,
OK, what's the good order?
I was surprised to realize
how open a problem that
still is, even from the expert
who's developing the key code.
So approximate minimum degree,
of course, by that word
you see that it allows freedom.
There are also
decisions to be made
when minimum degree is a
tie between several nodes,
as it commonly is.
And it's rather nice to
get a MATLAB movie that
shows the order
in which nodes are
eliminated, edges are removed
from the graph, from the mesh.
You'll see that.
All right, I'm ready to go
ahead now to some comment
on Gauss-Seidel.
Maybe I'll put that here.
In fact, maybe I'll just
take the same matrix.
So now I want to remember,
what is the Gauss-Seidel method
for A*x equal b.
What's the iteration now?
And again, A will be the same:
2, minus 1, zero; minus 1,
2, minus 1.
My favorite, OK.
So all these iterations,
you remember,
are splittings of the matrix.
Some of the matrix goes
on the left-hand side.
That's the preconditioner.
So it's P, the
preconditioner that's
sort of close to A in some
sense, but easy to work with,
multiplies the new thing
and on the other side
is A minus A-- the rest
of the matrix-- that
multiplies the old plus
the right-hand side b.
Let's just remember again, that
if we converge to the point
where this is the same as this,
then we have the right answer.
We have the right answer because
if that's the same as that,
P*x is the same as P*x, this
comes over on the other side,
A*x equals b.
So when it converges, it
converges to the right answer,
but you remember that
the key equation was
that the new error is
the old error multiplied
by this matrix I minus P inverse
A. That's the iteration matrix,
you could say.
I just get it when I multiply
both sides by P inverse.
And so the problem is choose
P so that this is easy to do
and at the same time,
this has small eigenvalues
or as small as you can get.
So the Gauss-Seidel is
a particular choice,
which takes the lower-- P is
the lower triangular part here.
So P is, so I just thought I'd
better write down, explicitly:
Gauss-Seidel takes
that, with zeros there,
as multiplying-- that's
P. And what's P minus A?
It's the rest.
And it's been moved
to the other side
so the rest is going to be the
strictly upper triangular part.
And because it's moved
over to the other side
it'll have a plus sign.
It'll be 1 and 1.
x_k plus b.
I just write it out so that
you see, totally explicitly,
how being triangular makes
the solution step immediate.
Because the first equation will
tell us the first component,
right?
The first equation,
because it's triangular
there's only an entry here.
And by the way, all these
codes, including Tim Davis's
minimum degree codes,
their very first step
is reorder the
equations if necessary
to guarantee that the main
diagonal has no zeros.
We want to know that in advance.
So that you just
do, let's assume it.
Of course, for us it
happens automatically.
OK, so that's not zero.
And that first equation
gives us the first component,
then we know the first
component so we use it here,
and the second equation tells
us what the second component is.
We use that second component
in the third equation
to find the third component.
So there's no loss of
speed compared to diagonal
and actually, it's faster
because the storage--
we're changing-- we're using
the new first component to find
the second and the new second
component to find the third,
so we can overwrite
x_k by x_(k+1).
Let's see.
I guess if I had space and had
prepared I would figure out
what this matrix is.
Maybe you could do that.
Figure out what-- here's
P. It's invertible.
P inverse is going
to be quite simple.
Actually, it would
be extremely simple.
You'll be able to see its
eigenvalues immediately.
We could stop to do it,
but I think if you do it,
it's more valuable.
So we would find that its
eigenvalues were below 1
and that they were the squares
of the Jacobi eigenvalues,
so the method is twice
as fast as Jacobi.
But it has the same good feature
of damping the high frequencies
and the same bad feature
of not very much damping
the low, smooth
part of the error.
Now we're ready for multigrid,
which is intended to solve it.
So multigrid is going to be--
the point is, by changing grid,
by changing from the fine
grid to a coarse grid,
the smooth oscillation
doesn't look so smooth.
On the coarse grid,
its effective frequency
is effectively doubled and it's
moving over in the direction
where the smoother
can attack it.
We'll see that happen.
So now, I have to, really--
this begins the lecture
on multigrid, which
is going to take,
certainly, today and Friday.
There's a very good book
by Briggs and others.
He wrote the first
edition of the book
and coauthored the second one.
And it's beautifully
short and clear and simple
and this presentation will
follow the same exposition
that the book does.
So the key idea is
to see what-- how
to go from a fine
grid problem, so this
is on the fine grid
with step size h.
So this A_h is our problem.
A_h is A. A_h, b
sub h, we're looking
for u_h on the fine grid.
Fine grid means
lots of mesh points,
lots of unknowns, big problem.
OK, so the idea is
going to be, somehow,
to-- let me just
start with two grids.
Well, you can see what you do
on the fine grid at the start.
You iterate.
You use Gauss-Seidel
or Jacobi, whatever.
Maybe three times.
Maybe three
iterations, but don't
continue to a
thousand iterations,
it's a waste of time.
Then, here is the real--
this is the multigrid part.
The multigrid part
is going-- you
get an answer after
a few iterations,
after you've smoothed it.
You compute this
residual, which is
the amount you're wrong in
the equation, the difference
between the right side
and the left side.
I can put h's here
too, to emphasize.
This is residuals being
computed with what we have,
which is on the fine grid.
Now here's the change of grid.
Number two says, restrict
to a coarse grid.
Take that r_h, that residual
which is probably a bit smooth,
and move it to the coarse grid.
So the coarse grid we
identify by the fact
that its mesh width
is twice as big, 2h.
And so we're going to
need some restriction,
so the input to
this multigrid is
to decide on a restriction
matrix, how shall we take
values that are
given on a fine grid
and restrict them
to a coarse grid?
Of course, one restriction
is-- and it's not
that bad-- is just to
take the values of r
that are on the coarse grid
at every other grid point,
use those.
Or we could take into
account the neighbors.
You see the question.
So this is coming now
in this restriction.
So the restriction
is, restriction R,
this is fine to coarse,
and we have this question
of use neighbors or not?
That will enter.
Well, the decision on
what the matrix R is.
That's the key.
OK, so we choose
an R, we restrict,
and we have now a
half-size problem.
Well, half-size in 1D,
quarter-size in 2D,
eighth-size in 3D because
the mesh width has
doubled in every coordinate.
Now I've put solve.
I better put quotes around that.
Well, solve the problem
on the coarse mesh.
So the idea is that
that's much faster.
Well, you might
say, what problem?
Well, we have to
create, somehow,
the matrix on the coarse mesh.
That's not necessarily
given to us.
We start the
problem with A, A_h,
the matrix on the fine grid.
Can I just mention
that this is probably,
this v-cycle-- that
letter v is supposed
to suggest going down to
the coarse mesh and back up
to the fine mesh.
And the standard
notation in all the
multigrid books is a capital
V. And why do I use a small v?
This is my educational
contribution.
Capital V is appropriate
when you have several meshes.
You go to 2h, you go to 4h,
you go to 8h, back to 4h, back
to 2h, back to h.
So a deeper multigrid.
So it would look
more complicated.
I would repeat this idea
instead of solve here.
Instead of solve at the 2h
level, which of course, I'm
not going to do exactly anyway.
But if I was in a
big V-cycle I would
iterate a few times to smooth
here, just as I did here.
I would iterate using
weighted Jacobi or something
and then go down to the 4h mesh.
So restrict to the 4h mesh.
So you can see that I would
stay in this little loop
to get to the bottom, 8h, and
then I would start back up.
So I think it's a good
idea to use a small letter
v to tell us-- rather than
saying two-grid capital
V-cycle, I'm just going
to use a small v to signal
right away that it's two grids.
Fine, coarse, fine.
OK, so we have some solution,
not necessarily exact
and actually, there
isn't that much point
in getting it exact
because what we want
is to move toward
the right answer.
And notice that I'm
looking here at the error,
rather than looking at A_(2h),
u_(2h), the actual solution.
What I'm computing with
is the correction term.
So this is the correction
term that I find.
So this is the
residual over here.
this is the A_(2h) that
I still have to choose,
and then solving that
will give me a correction,
but that correction
is on coarse mesh.
I've only had that correction
E_(2h) defined on the 2h mesh.
So now comes the other
part of multigrid.
Get back to the fine
mesh, climb back up.
I take that E_(2h) and
apply an interpolation.
I need to create
an interpolation.
This is going to
be coarse to fine.
And I have to decide
how to do that.
Once I've decided
it that gives me
a correction at the
fine mesh level, which
is where I'm really working,
so I make the correction
and I have a better answer.
And probably, I
iterate a few times--
that would be called
a post-smoother--
on that correction.
And maybe that's where I stop or
maybe I repeat little v-cycles,
but that's not brilliant.
If you're going to do
multiple-- if you're
going to repeat multigrid,
it's much more efficient
to move to more and
more coarse meshes
because the
calculations on these
are way faster than
on the fine mesh.
You see, rather
than-- I much prefer
to go way down and back
up than a lot of v-cycles.
I mean, that would
be a small w-cycle.
And not brilliant.
Much better to use a big
V-cycle or a big W-cycle.
There's a place for W-cycles,
but they're capital W-cycles,
because you want
to get down where
it is very fast, very
inexpensive and in fact,
so efficient that
multigrid achieves
this holy grail of giving you
an answer with whatever accuracy
you want-- giving you an
answer in O of n operations.
n being the matrix size.
Capital N squared
in our example.
So that's the fantastic
result from multigrid.
So I'll come back to this,
but just say if the size of A
is n, which is capital N in 1D,
capital N squared, capital N
cubed, then the multigrid
works in O of n flops,
floating points operations.
Not even log n, which we
think of for the-- n log
n we think of for the FFT, for
the Fast Fourier Transform.
But here's it's
actually order of n.
That really is a
goal worth achieving.
So we know what the
smoothers might be.
It's the I and the
R that are new.
And then the analysis
of convergence,
why does it converge?
But to use the method,
and-- so by the way,
projects using multigrid
are totally welcome also.
So let me take the
interpolation I. So what's that?
Coarse to fine.
Let me imagine I'm in 1D,
so there's the x direction.
Here's one end of the
interval, here's the other end
of the interval and suppose my
boundary conditions are zero.
So this is the coarse mesh
and let me put in here,
make it the fine mesh.
So at this point,
I have an answer
on the coarse mesh, which
satisfies the boundary
condition, and let's say
it's there, there, and there.
OK, and I need values on the
fine mesh at the other points.
Of course, I'm going
to use these values
when I interpolate them.
That word interpolation
means-- implies,
keep what you have
on the given points.
And I'm just going to
do linear interpolation.
So halfway there, halfway
there, and halfway there.
So I'm inputting-- ignoring the
boundary conditions, the zeros,
I'm-- it's going to
be 5 by 2 I think,
this matrix I in this example
will be 5 by 2 because it has 2
inputs, these, and
it has 5 outputs.
And what's the matrix?
Well, for the second
and fourth outputs
it uses exactly--
this multiplies x,
or I should say u, u_1 and u_2.
Let me see if I'm-- if I'll
follow the notes in-- the notes
use v_1 and v_2 for the coarse
mesh values to avoid h, 2h,
extra subscripts.
So this height is v_1,
this height is v_2,
and I'm going to take-- this'll
be the new u_1, u_3, and u_5.
And u_2 I'm going to save.
I better put I and make this
into a true equation, I*v.
This is going to give me the
values u_1, u_2, u_3, u_4,
and u_5.
So u_2 is just v_1.
u_4 is just v_2.
No problem.
And what do I do
with the other ones?
Let's see.
I guess u_1 is halfway
between v_1 and 0.
OK, so it's 1/2.
u_1 is just 1/2 v_1,
it doesn't involve v_2.
u_3, which is sitting
here is half of these,
so it's half of this and half
of that where this was nothing.
Then u_4 was the same
as v_2, just take v_2.
And what's u_5?
u_5 is half of v_2
and half of zero.
So it's a simple matrix,
the interpolation matrix.
It's just reasonable
to use the letter I
and we all recognize, here
it's a rectangular matrix, not
the identity.
I doesn't stand
for identity here,
it stands for interpolation.
OK, so I hope you can
focus on the matrix.
And if it was much, much
bigger, but still in 1D,
it wouldn't look very different.
Each column would
have a 1/2, 1, 1/2.
That's a typical part of
the interpolation matrix.
It uses the value v_1, saves
it at the center point,
uses half of it at the
previous point, and half of it
at the right-hand point.
And similarly, you see it's sort
of a typical rectangular matrix
in signal processing as well.
I have to say something
about what happens in 2D
because our problems are in 2D.
Maybe I just draw
a typical 2D mesh.
These are the coarse values,
this is the coarse mesh and now
I'll-- and of course,
we'll save those values.
I will have a 1, so
it'll save those values
when it goes to the fine mesh,
the fine mesh being half.
So I just have to
decide what to do there.
So question mark.
What value shall I
take-- oh, I suppose
I have to decide there, too.
These are all new points
and what shall I do.
I'm just going to stay with
linear interpolation, which
is quite fast and satisfactory.
This value will be the
average of those two.
This value will be
the average of those
and what will this
one be in the center?
It's the average of
these four, of course.
And that's what we'll get.
Actually, that Kronecker product
business, a Kronecker product
of a 1D matrix like
that with itself
would be a 2D interpolation
that would do exactly this.
We can write it out
more fully, but it's not
fun to write out really fully
because if this is 5 by 2,
then I2D would be 25 by 4.
So we're right away, even
on this tiny, tiny problem,
we're right away up
to 25 internal mesh
points on the fine mesh.
That's the matrix that
I want you to see.
And, the natural choice
for R is the transpose.
So one possible choice-- and it
will, the answer will be yes,
we do use neighbors.
So R will be the
transpose of I. Actually,
I'll need a factor here.
I think it's 1/2.
Let me just see what it is.
Let me see why we need a little
multiple there to make things
right.
So there's my matrix
I, so I'm just
going to transpose it and
let me factor 1/2 out of that
so you see these matrices
without fractions inside.
That would be 1, 2, 1.
So I'm going to transpose that.
1, 2, 1, 0, 0.
0, 0, 1, 2, 1.
So I factored 1/2 out
of I when I did that.
And then I believe that
I need another 1/2 here.
I think I need 1/4.
And what do I mean
by needing 1/4?
Of course, the main
point is that this
is the transpose of this.
And you'll see that that
preserves the symmetry.
That's just sort of the
natural thing to pick.
Not the only possibility,
but it's very good
to connect the restriction
with the interpolation.
Of course, you can't
take the restriction
to be the inverse of
the interpolation.
Why not?
I mean that sort of mental idea
is that the restriction goes
in one direction and
the interpolation
in the other direction.
So why not just let one be
the inverse of the other?
Well of course, that matrix
doesn't have an inverse.
I mean its rank is only 2.
When we do a restriction we're
going to lose information,
the interpolation
can't put it all back
because we threw it away when we
restricted to the coarse mesh.
Now why 1/4?
I think it's just if we had
all constants, like all ones,
as our mesh values,
we would want
to get all ones for
the restriction.
So if I multiply this matrix
by the vector of all ones--
so assuming you remember
where R comes in,
if I just copy
this equation, you
remember that I go from the
h mesh, it's fine to coarse.
So R times ones on the fine
mesh, all ones on the fine mesh
gives ones on the coarse mesh.
That's why I wanted that-- you
see, if I multiply by all ones
then that multiplication gives
me 1 plus 2 plus 1 equal 4
and I need to divide by
4 to get back to the 1.
You quickly discover
that that just arises
because of a change of scale.
It's just a factor of 1/2.
In 2D that 1/2 there
would change to 1/4.
In 3D it'd be 1/8.
It's just the scaling
to preserve constants.
And now the remaining
question is, what's A_(2h).
That's the other matrix
here that we're not given.
We're given the
A_h, our problem.
We choose an R and we choose
an I and if we're smart,
one's the transpose
of the other.
And then the question
is, what's A_(2h)?
And there's a beautiful answer,
so let me just say what it is.
A_(2h), the coarse mesh matrix,
is the fine mesh matrix,
but I need to do first-- if this
is going to apply to the coarse
mesh guys, the v's, I have
to do an interpolation.
You'll see it here.
This is 5 by 5 in my problem.
So I need to first
do the interpolation
to get from a vector of length
2 up to a vector of length 5.
Then this and then
the restriction.
That's terrific.
That's A_(2h).
So this is A_(2h) and
we'd better do an example.
I guess it's going
to be next time.
So that'll be the first thing
for next time, would be to see,
okay, for the standard
second difference A_h,
for these piecewise linear
interpolation and restriction,
what comes out as A_(2h)?
Do we get the standard
second difference
on the coarse mesh, which you
really hope we do and we do.
This will be the second
difference, in our example,
on the coarse mesh.
So that this middle step of
multigrid is exactly what
we would have expected.
What we would've had if we
set up the problem originally
on the coarse mesh.
But now we're going to get
an answer that we take back
to the fine mesh.
OK, so I'll do that next time.
Some homeworks here that I
held for an extra two days
and now I'm returning and
some thoughts to go up
on to the website about
possible projects,
but actually, I
expressed a lot of them
at the beginning of the lecture.
OK, thanks.
Good.